what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
official trailer for The Little Mermaid
join with someone who we don't really do
any videos together
hey John how are you I'm good it's nice
to see you how are you good took a break
from the Oscars to come here yes I did
how you liking it I don't I'm not
watching I don't really care
you're really missing out they're
nailing it I heard a couple of the wins
and I was like all right I make this one
this one bothered me a little bit but
anyway uh no seriously jamaicers that's
ridiculous let's see what they have a
whole argument about that right now
let's see this trailer's all of power
and uh yeah leave a like people
[Music]
whoa oh is this when Ariel saves him
yeah it must be
gor verbinsky's Little Mermaid
yes it is
[Music]
broke the rules
hello the above World a man was drowning
I had to save him this obsession with
humans has to stop Javier Bart dance
I had no idea
so she's a mixed ethnicity I can help
you you can't live in that world unless
you become a human yourself is that even
possible
that's what I live for
it's got the laugh down oh yeah
The Voice
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out
you idiot
oh my goodness
got a lady Scuttle and anthroporifically
corrects her
biologically correct crap
oh my God
[Music]
serious Aquaman Vibes yeah I know
he's a human you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
Kiss the Girl
hey we got the fireworks in there that's
nice
are we wow we gotta we gotta skim that
trailer yeah here in that party I caught
this video I want to say her name's like
hi Jamie or hey Jamie or she did Part of
Your World with this like creepy
Snapchat filter now whenever I hear that
song I think of that video good good
that's probably some of the technology
they use to bring all of this to life
all right first order of business we
gotta just check out I forget the
seagull's name so there's Scuttle yeah
so they made it a girl yeah it sounds
like Aquafina oh is it Aquafina yeah I
think so she got that rasp yeah yeah you
might be right not my Scuttle I'm not
gonna lie Sebastian threw me way off yes
yeah absolutely I'm still wrapping my
mind that's a little disturbing it was
really disturbing very much distracted
by that
um I had no idea that that's what they
were going to be going for here yeah
because this this has there's something
strange about the visuals to me where
you have this mixture where it's like
all right you're fully embracing the
fantasy side of it you know like Javier
Bardem and this King Trident outfit and
then they're like let's go super
freaking real now look at the animals
and have them talk let's get that Lion
King Technology in here and that's the
part that was really is so jarring to me
did you see that yeah I think it
especially for a movie like this that
still wants to remain a pretty locked in
fantasy I am curious to see how that
will affect the tone overall because
Sebastian is such an important and
endearing character such an animated
character yeah like he's not for me that
sounds stupid he's a very expressionist
character yeah so to see him it's
so funny
when you first see it maybe it'll work
within the the context of it
um I I like the look of the cast so far
I don't know any I don't know who's
playing Prince Eric I don't know who
this guy is
um he's really hot whoever he is he's
really hot Rob Marshall who did the
fourth Pirates movie makes sense why
this kind of does have some on Stranger
Tides Vibes and on Stranger Tides did
feature mermaids as well yeah the best
of the Pirates is the bestest Revitalize
everything we loved
um the parts of the cinematography
that's semi-concern me is when it's live
like here yeah when or what like why is
it like this gray washed out color about
the colors yeah and I was not on the
train of people when that poster dropped
of like oh it's too dreary looking like
there's certainly moments to look
yeah they put that poster on there
people color correcting it and going see
this is what real color saturation looks
like but you know I mean when they're
getting you know thrown around by the
waves it's plenty dreary but yeah that's
a Quant that qualifies for that scene
yeah but when you you juxtapose yeah the
CG heavy stuff with some of this more
tangible location shooting I think all
of it has sort of a weird like there's
some element of saturation that does
feel like it's maybe a little bit
missing and I can't tell if it's if it
feels grayed out or if that's some kind
of choice that they make it looks great
out to me yeah I'm on that side right
now because I think I understand when
you have to make it a little darker when
you're under water and stuff because
you're making up for a lot of this
visual effects which does look I mean to
me it looks pretty good right now sure
um the hints that we've got of Ursula I
think are pretty cool uh she's really
seems like she's bringing her to life uh
I'm I'm not distracted by the fact that
it's Melissa McCarthy because I thought
it was going to be I thought it was
gonna be more Melissa McCarthy's
dropping a bunch of jokes stuff like
that yeah it seems like she's paying
respect to it the thing though is is
that something with the visuals it's
like they don't look underwater it looks
like they they they're not under water
they they put water effects around you
yeah you know it looks like they put
things like little particulates in the
foreground and then they really got
everybody's hair to do that sort of
weightlessness thing yeah that was one
of my big concerns and and I get that
James Cameron can't just direct
everything water related after something
like the way of water anything that
takes place in a deep sea environment
like this you kind of it begs to feel
that immersive and some of these
underwater shots unfortunately do feel a
bit green screeny yeah I mean it looks
like the colors are really popping in in
this particular sequence here sure yeah
it was one of these it was probably like
a musical number yeah not even sure what
musical number this is supposed to be is
it under the sea perhaps all the
different creatures thought of every
other musical number with that one yeah
yeah hey you know I mean yeah that's I'm
sure a primed Disney fan will be like
actually no if you go back to the
animated movie it'll probably correlate
to this but yeah yeah I mean it's got a
interesting look because yeah I mean
it's the it's the little mermaid right
right now what they're showing us is The
Little Mermaid movie yeah it's just the
the visuals themselves have this mixture
of going for embracing the fantasy
sometimes just straight up looking like
an animated movie other times they're
trying to go for the realistic dark
grittiness uh and then they go for some
of the animals for that Lion King
prehistoric Planet Apple TV effects
absolutely sure it's just this hybrid of
a bunch of different and I'm wondering
like is it is it is the visual
experience going to gel other is it
gonna be wonky yeah and I'm and I'm
fascinated to find out because Rob
Marshall I don't always I feel like in
some ways he knows how to do a musical
and stuff like that I don't love every
ear Mark of his Direction style four
musicals but this does look very
sweeping and classic and like you know a
big costume and locations kind of period
yeah mixed with an undersea fantasy both
of those elements I think are exciting
uh but at the same time yeah I'm not I I
don't know like this seems like a big
undertaking for somebody like to adapt
The Little Mermaid into live action
seems like something you would need both
a person who really understands musicals
for but also someone who's like a
technical whiz and I don't associate
yeah so he's done a lot of big
Productions like into the woods and
everything but I don't I I'm with you on
that side of oh when it comes to the
visual effects Department he hasn't
really done anything where I'm
necessarily jazzed by what he's produced
like this looks like an animated movie
right here yeah like this part with
Ursula this is straight up just 2D
animation yeah it does and this this was
the most exciting passage of the trailer
along with like seeing all the different
creatures in The Ensemble together yeah
like Ursula really pulls me in in a way
where I felt like if this was you know
some kind of live stage adaptation they
were like Melissa McCarthy's gonna step
in and play Ursula I'm like that's a
cool step for her as an actor to show
off her show tunes chops and maybe reign
in some of her unique isms to embody
this character and I mean how uh Hallie
looks uh you know perfectly charismatic
as Ariel but I also really want to kind
of get to know her through this uh yeah
I didn't feel like I really got a sense
of any of the characters much more than
stoic Trident yes yeah Trident that's
all I really got to understand but
anyway uh yeah this was a fine trailer
sure but uh what did you guys think
about it did you did you like it I mean
it's suitable yeah it's it's a little
mermaid trap I was weirdly more enhanced
by the uh entrance by the because like I
think I think like the the vocal sound
great like everything sounds great uh
but I was more weirdly jazzed by the
small teaser trailer I know I think it's
just that promise of your imagination
gets to fill in all the rest yeah you
see it here and you're like this kind of
looks like it's getting there yeah it
looks a tad in Conflict what's up who
knows could be could be worthwhile uh
anyway guys leave your thoughts down
below uh be sure to subscribe leave a
like and uh we will catch you all soon
foreign